welcome to the session to bouwt how to
gray de napier
de george helpers love and naturally
filmpers
axel i want to use maybe you are
developer in a you probably know what
you like and you know what you want to
you so weird and just here to conform  to
date his hope so my name is kevin
bouwmeester he hears it google-and his
kiss him engineer and partly apogee team
so out join google in november sorry
acquisition and now the taking you too
short in drugs in just a few slides boot
eps liner using  gps these days' en
en is apogee is doing bij dpa is met
de wet al gore demo
morel show apogee hecho project and how
you can use that to actually op 220 goal
to great the size
that will have two models
of abn amro and always and evie memories
going to the journey where die actually
transforming the bank inch your sins gets
more ditch aim that him epa is of course
and so great developer portal and
actually jolan  re in l innovative
and the front payments and
banking just that thing set lets let
he stormt help that at that and at the
time i get to the jentje of a pretty
good guy who takes dogs you
should look like and hopefully lot of
new ideas which i could use in your own
programs so for who get started at
let's just think about my epa is the so
the question to the audience
how view all warning for camp new
arena position the idea where you offer
eps
oh wow great great for  the keyser first
room it was there was a familiar round
rate before you realize video that will determine the
script how is she how she developer who is
using epa is it 50% may be great place
to no great show this may be preaching
to the choir  je stork we so we
slide the views such a scan of time this
round epa is the cheesemonger eat him for
the first question you problem ever
in this show
business the palmers have more tea and yet my
interpreter it's more laudun and that this is through
bus  iness het so this to businesses that
song ticket by epa is dr try to offer
services en deda
then ep ice and this dh comes from
systems right back and systems
which kan week obel
price koen van and also bang figure
main cable silent that i could die brent
news systems like some to build an app
engine in google cloud or no jeff
thatcher and then here on request
the thing is your hand is
dh and services to be consumed by your
customers and partners with chocolate breed
live and also in charlie with
organization maybe for in journal app
store to go and please
zo ik you into how this work section you
come down to this which is the ditch
door value chain and this is so the slide
oui oui oui oui think you're really
important it met apogee  is what we used
to my customers projectile i try to
investigate and we want to go to which
the dit stoney dood door geesjen
schoon to achieve all the way to the
your and twigs cymbals not to be used
for r&d so tired bent shannon mid deltjes
die developer
de Keizer is the question it the second
question ayayayayay
en dasty do you team of course the team
lets try to upgrade icp correct right to
secure it
train toe katie's ik Juist available
canning them out there and that actually
two aspects to the station  valley cheney
left left site is your smother
consumption where your ex left your e price
the has the be used after the
documentary has a get the found for
developers get him in get him to board
and then
seemed a start want things and want cool
new solutions  just less to my part
which the murder technical gate where you
axel i want you get b the family covering
systems a man to medium available in a
secure way i do diamond shape it the traffic
management under not get analytics to
under use and she never thing like  that
your loving you think about so all
touch to at least two aspects boot it
about focus primarily on the left side
switches about building a community
ranger' epa and bill things de  veloper or
take care napier tot sorry sheetfed press
cowardly
as far as i slept three types or details
go 13 service and your polyol of
millions this is
ep eyes that's there you sensoa if they
in my car services die sorry guys i
sleep systems in sync and deeply won't
you think about om boring governance of
jungsheft' proper service
us olympia is beautiful that that's the left for
this time i want to inflict essence interactions
with a purposes xlii sepia's
old then app becomes your web app
specifically for making sure that people
can interact with your  organization and
their company slight netflix for exam
how do you put now with the pig-scale how
f
specific epa is for specific device
a specific
interactions that they that he offer and
the purposes of course to make it's
formative and is best as possible  for a
user experience and this is it
technical light graffiti welcome in
value the five six you really switch
day jones and the
de ep xlii wants to combine civil
aviation one  just to make it easy for
device to know cities and countries
lasting awful and sleep border
dare thing is the epic sports doctor this is
typically warious see that also a
party horror and technology
see something new right report of
offering physical production
your epa show interactions and can  also
be
a product that your offer to your
customers or to your partner's for
simple and could also think about
monetizing so
asking money for this project raichu
offering santing so the you can
built sensation strategy on
top of your epia is so that i put
die cpf in an eco systems and think
about the facebook epia he the google
maps cp yes the twitter epa so already
public single system close the tag
marino's
we this turns out the beautiful stevia is
actually en euro in journal to
organizations at the mini joost
met in the organization and for apps or
maybe just for apps that put the
company as parent in the market and the
I was interesting happening in  the
medieval where we used to laugh
organizations
is not save white partners and are
business to business model players to
offer
technologies seems swift of ftp in fel
street chauffeur may be sending tips to
each other and we see that these
interactions arnoud turning to become
more more
king over hey guys game
sorry i think what is most eps ai
internal
and mine never your vps there actually the
sepia is the advice pedophile develop
for us
why why should i care about be
developers left or conflict so despite
it also to customers and  dc again
offerings service more big bang for
whom you hurt retailer and this developer
internship lessons user epa and dha joyce
and yes you can be right with the criticism
about a little bit more dazzle of
friction that your ex jr into every
direction du du jury die  is not the you
do you have that developer slav and so that is
developers they don't want to face time
so that the lazy it someone who does
incision he has sign un sdg  je just a
few lines of code add in pull
charger company den berg happy en has
there happy er ze chance' use your eps more
more bit more great ideas and more
interactions and that's more than
actually does this mean that sorry there were
not change  business model for ar
customer's the mad king sure they take and
do the the tank they're doing it fits a
retailer the selling product is sister the
buoys selling public cool episode
more attractive to you the banner new york and
sister words and that's my  job boards that
developers care by typepad
so that my traction name just want to
go over few things which which we've
seen within organizations that actually
make great detail and this is my list of
seven things just kept
that the that's all move
into a demo where he students can
show what of the slide here so
things like zo service
light gray documentation war fiction
plumbing tremendously important and the
most popular epia progra  mma would der d
do I shackly so first is like this
one poking the screenshots of customers or
apogee with derk developer and the
this thing wat je stisch companies that
they have really easy develop more words
quick to discover becomes eliasar met
interactions developers can have  these
organizations and is free easy to go
push button and get access i merely
maybe it's not fully met beach mug
tea therefore maybe it's a lesser die zo
rate limit om net met it's easy to get
exercise easy to go into de developer
drink and get started
jelle things monastery in je deleden
to this if you might get started in
not to bars in it you to make yourself
in a me to the organization and if i
need you yes you became your flight and the
meeting really has the time you  win your database
and the extreme x den daele friction and
people developers leeuwen easily turn
from monet pia to another
has t can get started quickly right
lucas je sheetfed press they want to doing
gladly
zo this  is a screenshot of in developer
portal of ticket master
polio yard drawbar tickets we temper cent
of their ticketsale too fast going
through
epa is how you a hot selling and even
players or to third party apps to
apps and alec to think that this is just
speak  if it anyway to sign up something so
who do you
find yourself there epa is the get started
we this adr finding because of developers
so after then also mole other fields on
there to be filled in death note social
security number lighting that you don't
think it  bout
corsini tricks that trams of
conditions terms and conditions with
now through something and many weeks you can
scroll sure it a this since
and dennis builds documentation
to know how your a keywords
so the chablis place where you pray xlii
scroll dpa is  heaven
overview and get some more title song
which he she and it to use with your eyes
to go with primer she can provide an
aging like that their great tool would
13th day like open napi  er just week als
water which can help you out with the
clinch and drove for my ep he design
great and beautiful documentation and
that's what you want to offer chio
developers
it's not just documentation rides in
you you can show your love for
dokumentation with the  view detail design
sucks and not going to be successful so
developer sexy noot in don't like 4
curse to the slides
it's like that all books and save your
kids quite easy dwell on the
death wish you think about cry
recurring doc also  hear replay sitting
bull seat dox word training dox its
something can i know the start complicated
and that's xlii view the full suits
assign model s xlii work and salt and
developer staff to research for long
time has a reed all the documentation
to actually on  the stand watch r ep that's
so
tone to death and does something like
this en zo the developers an audience
versus your address and and you tell me
you is rest profession tried freddy guy
who you die  do you work she won't do
love story ladder research to extra us
maya's nevertheless of use which art
entity which i could get to rate from the
teacher at ikea list or search en you can
create entities update and you can de
let him en is  quite easy hell experience
works
davy building's to whom there is a protocol
for santing
this is my toes make any developer
happy zoo der bunch of other things like
lector de barbies i give you an hype en
media which match ark en re vinckx
new tools that you  can can offer to
the developers
where pcm and primary google is a
fortress and in white your pc
which is a product or that you could use
their performances really important and
the f a preacher who who keeps you the
fire ipe workshops who know change a
lot of things like give you all and
mentioned earlier
where the the 5 section apps for extra oil
what did nothing tasty curry and the eat
you make sure exec lida is sharing
his mouth
something like seventh device problem measurements
fiel  dgoals de get the divider the nothing
else hide media
which section epia how in in ever
response der ze jora mormot pure els zo
developed at shiritori sponge en follow
the url sender over monet pierre go
to another en ex-lief full full delete
followed the  links zo my use the one you
think this and music that sense of
course i could actually bill the media you
that's one dan at developer speakers
who both never really nothing with as oil
fully functional thinking at dpa design
holds for security has the stick
when it  pink's that kind of developer soon
so has four building your own sep
I'll be there palette times developers and your
seat developers world is watching after
use to use or epa and the 16th that's the
security but why not gonna show you body
bag and back in that  benefit you the
source code anywhere the developer is
basically in the dark ride so and he took
a ring steven consolation is right
so you don't become to this you think like
oh what success can we recognize the
facto standard for security one you not
to user authentication
is user can change music hour and choice
for token and then it also becomes a sign
the selection of epa x specifically for
one and only one user for one and only
one device
ray price for some pale  get location or
get get dox location rono don't you take that
as a vibration user
authentication for those gps mighty fine
just to heaven e tai chi
but it's wet you don't used more
secure
jps make it easy where you know and your
sander client a  dior nike previously
eyewear that's
sufficient
and i mean we should we then
grandiflora' if you doing a great job
nah think your eyes will be really great
and develop tries so jessica build
this
the chip intake it little further and the
most on ray price
of  camps is older looks like google blue
thor twitter
pf it is who says the case discuss the
whole these for developers the start using
your ep huis van der goot crust has
the or race test case for the me  est
popular program
platforms my coach java nuts pyton
and of course monitor for the jpy met
also provides source code of depa so this
beautiful ornament that er ar links to get up for
some
and then there's your names pink must
canova a console
live testing and the  scan of cities gerard
zo had to new develop judge yourself become
stumping leaders make it really
easy for the van op the try-outs die jpa
nl de show this in my demo where him xlii
can goin to do portal and see this
suitcase napier de de  like and just make a
few also if the cia reep adwords see what
kind of sponge get back
what prem there would i a sendin word old
actually need to registered workout
actually doing to install the sdk was
to make it reeleezee and your
problems a million with  a hello world
program
this makes an free easy for developer to
to the images hello world en week al in
some times the time to first hello world
cup i just and reduces it is so that
sit
this will be the box is my l  ist of seven
pink's russia and move on to how i can
to this yourself summer and a switch to
my laptop you
see the civique and open up app jets
hot after that a show view developer
granules and has there time which at things
the third there is like  they then show you the
technical portlets connection' lead you
to expose and do you have your bek and
sisters
tools
this is the developer portal of tomtom and
their customers apogee
der actually camper of google maps
such as vinking surah showroom here with
and lighter develop produce  a much
dat harting did surksum attention is
wel
je bornino tomtom they sold is
navigation devices which i could put en
de wind screen of je car to find your
way van etui met nobody lee using
them or write us your navigation on your
phone or have  built into your car
zo dan stupidity switch once by business
model wat and the ex-lief oh well dat de
ddf greetings maps and routing services en
all that still really really valuable
zo des enchère  s focusing on and for them
eps armparty product bright
en under the many gates lessons
developer rich and exellius ko ko der and
so trunk what i do we there
epa so just took you against criticism
and so to those with maps online attitude
searching online  traffic
the term you have to switch things sports
equipment and his ep eye and
they're still the bridge
will you even go on and am trying to
discover reach and push the sepia eggs
catalog information on how de routing
eyeworks rotink emmy dan with single
routing  requests are batch
acknowledge from matrixx never just full
long go to specific dokumentation xlii
and that canning the
the technical information it makes
girl he as developer actually i am
looking for right parents do you
look like what can i do they piaggio the
primers had them  specific request look
like and how can i get starting in a bit
then scroll down a little bit tricider'
its ex ampel yuro as long as you copy and
give detail and mission d  at there is my
field missing
wimps de epa i can see write my be smal
has been there so long joel with the team and
tipi which to nice to be inserted you have
you kiers actually santing that requirements
developer not the provider 2 views dpa
has anton  as long as you registered on
don't get and you dude etsy
love you see there is
sophie go back to the de tomtom develop
more than this button get shirky
in the extra week mars me to sign up or
sign in now expert van account or
éditions
him sign in and from then on you i have to test
my list of apps so xlii the would be
the right idea spider solo radium
betting app
chat kreté have
a new mapping there was a
turn out could cure oh that he do them
with the war
dotx plant for security where u be
relactive back to the gap after the user
login
something one a tori so dear empty
for now in and pine turning a not
super vibe is antique again or i talked
about is so who is epi isense product
so front  under eps where i s  ran
grouped into these bundles i a use de
mapping nevia is a key user routing hey
guys and search at mindshare sepia so
funny and interested in maps and let's
press do the
tricycle dish a [ __ ] take your time to
read it' and then critique and so  my
measurement do you have something
sorry there is already you taste so this
is the puzzles tomtom they want to make
it is fractional is as possible and
easy as possible of more are those
fellow pop star using dpa
so fresh er sono approuvé workfloor
summer we don't  so click the bottom end there is
my ep aiki
tomtom seccelen using the sepia key to
keep track of i'm doing
and it the certain point when they think
and doing to many goals de maid contact
meer about chains subscription on the
my bloody hell no
it is developer in active
that's great a p direct a lot it mi
be choose notie activate en sleeve
de that the essence is the zipper this is
sorry he can't hear you which it finds
oh sorry she die die that reality is that
is  to be easy to get your key en then
cat can get started switch die epa
so sometimes think at ics then is to make
it a la bergère for develops to to star
juli dpa legal
two thirds of the portal and babies to
sum
organ party  net is mad king penis
possible to realize
df meet all of the family guy guy
begging differnz
payment so for simple there is android b
en under developer portal and i'm
searching your browser to dpa is
actually has is so console were
have me was form  or my last lights
so this console is actually quite
extensive for
pei you can see with you that media
payment week in android payment is
actually
some non cyrillic cure so by the
self security mechanisms in follow there der
they are there and hash to continue them  never
even one there are small times that
and all teams that then not so provider
when will you go click the hellers daisy
there is also an average tai chi there are
and aids mac
guess that sets require to make and
a jerk it l  uckily family want such a
letter so all to do is just
something grows then the stew turning and
then make all and in the score excuse and
i pilot where your measurements
and android p payment wit 12 of the
tradition dollars
then just through damascus  idol request and
i a seed response actually be
transferred
so much more they developer so what a
like bright a lot it is such a beer
jig enthusiastic about is well
and in this santing that organizations
axel iraq is trying to achieve right to
offer dairy pia  their services we
then so easy easy to discover and easy
to access
sonority you want to show you is aan de
technical parks this store valley check
which is more the right bart where je ex
lead time to get
services and they do i have to make it
available and snape via the secure
an ep ipads clearly designed and did
you sing that time
back to write deda for sam zo this is m
jets and downloaded and more to do you my
work i do you have teamworks
so in july can manage me  hey pia is a
circle tip you practically
me if there is actionaid by proxy that proxy
for santing in the back end is
so nice epa and around our showroom
comes that caravan tractor
and for those who viewer notch your
problems and the tunes it the dutch decor
en all idea expensive in the summer white
caravans and the the cups problem for
the details in joliens is the figure out
how he via caravan can be right back or
greater noida car the big question is how
he who can me caravan which what is the
maximum  counts oh so the sepia a sexy
helping we that and this is just neck simple
we this is i simple seems to show pepe
jeans erin
of functional tea to make this epa
it's the over view page of me epm the
ten gouge oil import  and is how do we go
can call it the url and the back-end
wimps de bek en de lift sommer in the
organization and in this case it's a
back-end of that ardie that the uw de rdw
the suitcase with agency the keeps track of
all the carson red in ellen's t from is
putting the dough dyke  angry were
license plate within this license plate
so part-up then
but when i open it up my trace
when i have a fisheye will dp acorns dat
er be executed
al dpi you chose the comment will be
visualized and i a quickly x-play nu
we  have she's doing in their
so hot can i do a channel public
have so project and physiology of the
screen
megaview chance and the one ex plein what
spots happening
so lamica the boat to their screen of
death' could she do
well it's wet there is  so the two
seasons in one background and have
my app here from test field the
license plate about my car and he profile
the know whether a type and caravan with say
that ensure my caravan is 2000 kilos
could so more and who catback information
but my car mount  ow that my corridor
knows whether the caravan request and the mixes
with vice is
just a portion of nano level that will
you my character with the i know alto
and eating its always a tip or
for your sportscars crus steel use the
cone a  l idea so that's why de ik de
caravan is too heavy
it read more about yep dat je sister
of the example to make an ep acorn
in the background which she detail en je
see that there is some items popping up
and at which will explain
oldies  make another call and quickly
miracle
and theres a spike is so through triekels
turk walk or walked but there lies and
how do you see we know flow from the app to
the backend and and response of the
backend bacteria so sex becomes oil
in epia proxy  is doing in apogee something
can or in the middle and it can do love
links
who in the middle can really do this security
so is ie the lion per block india i a
week all those cycles policies that is there
an objective verification kind
requires the app provides  napier one of
the few things are my my life threads
world ze perfect in gets too much
traffic which means that gloomy this may
be made using the ep year for medical
on what is really toe enthusiastic and
i want to test al de karssies
me  t typically de the spyker rest full
single block this and they will prevent
too much traffic and too much traffic is
not really a problem for apogee this
kind of m6 for the back and so dad's at
young to stop like left more thing
is [ __ ] simple caching zo  see my
check a call it was much quicker from
for net when we want seconds to fit
the tree so she wrote i stream
want secans for you colin des
picas who then a get to the body
double you i get dedalo this card i know
it
f cash so profane ian does caching
strategy course engagement on powder
european marketing san diego and going to
all technical details with that back end
xlii returns al de ddd noah this car
right side of the price de ketele price
of this post
very much the  weight of the rail scores
the rail line not really the koller or the
porsche it sometimes after death not so
explique anfieldroad exec lee was three
quarters for me do you have a shembek the
line deda
the show muse him a ja h  et is just a
quick symbol of what apogee cando
to the technical portion this so much each
a meteor epa is available met to
write security
dry detail tactical formats zo chester
conclut what you or see is
hi culture epia you may be illogical
or I samples about casual drinks  of
gps holder should look like what you
should not to and what you shoot do
and he hopes u of it is resting and you
at vodafone using your exposie your epa
is how we here waiting for you if you
have questions or je mond en tobias grau
tbm er ok sorry woud apogee and like to
see o lord has that searching
testing testing kees do you think for coming
and evergrey d
[Applause]